EMILY: Hello again.
Welcome back to the
"Flutter Boring Show."
We're going to be adding
caching to the Hacker News
App, a much requested feature.
FILIP: True.
EMILY: Actually
before that, I'm going
to jump in and add right now
when you tap on these stories,
you just see story.
I think in an earlier
iteration we had it
display the number of comments.
And we got rid of that
when we were no longer hard
coding things.
So we're going to add
it the proper way.
And I pulled up the Hacker
News API up on GitHub.
And this has all the fields.
And here you can see
that Descendence,
in the case of stories or
polls, shows the total comment
count, which is--
FILIP: Handy.
EMILY: Yes, conveniently named
Descendence, but you know.
So let us-- let's see.
That is in here.
I think it's like raw item.
Build item, there we go.
Article type, we want to
do article.descendence.
Oh, and that's an
int, so we want--
actually let's make that text.
It's the number of comments.
And that'll just say comments.
Great.
Look at that.
FILIP: That's awesome.
EMILY: 98 comments.
FILIP: Can you show another--
oh, nice.
EMILY: This blog has moved.
Yes.
OK, so and then,
we actually noticed
we had a bug that
we just implemented.
So Filip added
pulling in the stories
from the Hacker News API, from
the top and the news stories.
And right now, if you
tap between them--
oh, wait.
FILIP: Yeah.
It's just, I think,
it does show.
But it's so slow
because we're not
caching that it looks like
it's not changing sometimes.
If you like click
back and forth to--
EMILY: I see.
FILIP: So we should
probably implement--
EMILY: Maybe we should
implement some caching.
OK.
So to do that, let's
go into our block.
And so what we're doing is
we're pulling up, reading this--
let's see.
This is a list.
So what we want to
do is we can make a--
I was going to make a
hash map of article ID
to Article that has been parsed.
But, no?
FILIP: No.
Yeah.
Sure.
No, no, no.
I'm saying hm because I
thought we would just like put
the articles through some list.
And then we use it, or--
EMILY: Sure.
What I was thinking is
like so this takes the top,
say, 10 stories.
What if someone
posts another one?
If you get one updated
one, were you just going
to invalidate the whole list?
FILIP: Hm.
Good point.
EMILY: So if we put in a
hash map, we get one new one
and all the others
are still cached.
And so we can look
them up individually.
So yes, yours is quicker
for like a whole block.
But I think for 10 articles,
it's not going to be that bad.
So I was trying to
remember now, so in what--
actually, yeah.
Do we-- I was sitting
there watching you code it
and now I need to orient myself.
We are calling getting the
IDs, we take this list.
Where does this-- where
does this get called?
FILIP: In many places, actually.
Three.
EMILY: OK, so how about
instead, let's get rid of that.
How about we write
this to a list.
Or sorry, we'll take this
and store it in the hash map,
once we get those IDs.
No, no, no.
Actually, we're going to,
once we get the articles,
store that in the hash map.
So let's go to
definition of that.
FILIP: Right.
So, yeah.
OK.
So I was--
EMILY: You see what I'm saying?
FILIP: Yes.
I was thinking that the delay
is because just the first call,
but it's actually
because of all the 10
other calls for the articles.
Right?
Yes.
That's perfectly reasonable.
So yeah, what I wanted to
cache is like everything.
But Emily has a
much better point.
And like always
getting the latest IDs
and then reusing whatever
we have for the articles
themselves.
That's great.
Yes.
EMILY: So I'm
writing a hash map.
Hash map and article, and
then when we have that
update articles-- no, wait.
I was just there.
Where was it?
I apologize.
My font size is bigger
than I like it with this.
Get articles and update.
Here we go.
So now we have the list of IDs.
We have--
FILIP: I just checked that
article is a built thing.
So it will have good hash.
So that's good.
EMILY: Thank you for checking.
Sorry.
I just need to find--
we have initialize
articles, update articles,
I'm just like oh.
FILIP: We can rename initialize
articles with something
like kickstart or something.
Because that's only called
once in the [INAUDIBLE]..
EMILY: Well, I think
initialize has that--
what I'm just going
to do is I'm just
going to organize these things.
So I'm going to put
initialize kind of near--
well, we'll put it after our
declarations but near this.
Oh, and here's another
little bit of cleanup.
We have some declarations
here and some here.
Wait, no.
Those are getters.
Never mind.
So getter, getter, initialize,
close, get article.
So here's where we
want, in get article.
We want to say if our
cached articles contains
key of this ID--
actually, we could just
say, if it doesn't contain,
do the thing.
FILIP: A thing with
a throw as well.
EMILY: Yes.
Thank you.
And then, and if here we want
to say cached articles ID
equals results.
And then we'll say,
return cached articles.
FILIP: Oh, OK.
Interesting.
And then in this case, you'll
need else for the throw.
Otherwise you'll always throw.
EMILY: Oh.
Thank you.
Yep.
That would be sad.
FILIP: You would throw
my favorite error.
EMILY: Oh, yes, the
excellent error.
FILIP: But still.
OK.
Yeah, that was quick.
EMILY: OK, so now
hooray, an exception.
Oh, actually, you know why?
It's because I need to do
a hot restart because I
declared something.
FILIP: Contains key--
try calling null.
EMILY: What?
FILIP: Is it null?
FILIP: So, OK,
actually, I think my--
I'm going to restart this.
This is a new machine.
And I think maybe this
code is a little wonky.
I was noticing hot restart
was not quite happy with me.
Try again.
If this doesn't
work, then we can--
FILIP: Yes.
It's weird.
Cache [INAUDIBLE].
EMILY: Because it should
be-- it's like right here.
FILIP: Yeah, it
shouldn't be null, ever.
EMILY: That's funny,
though, that it
thought it was there but
then-- well, whatever.
So here.
FILIP: Yeah.
Nice.
EMILY: All right.
FILIP: All right.
EMILY: Great.
So there you have it.
That is how you do caching.
Basically in summary,
it's all within the block.
It's all hidden from the UI
because the UI doesn't care
how you get the information.
And it's just under
the covers, we're
return the data faster because
we have a little hash map.
FILIP: Yeah.
So that's great.
So I think that's been great.
What's next?
Do we say?
I think it's almost ready
to publish it to Play Store.
EMILY: Yeah.
So stay tuned.
And you can learn how to
publish your beautiful new app
to the Google Play Store.